distinguished guests
it's so good to see you again bill
because the last time we met was just a
month ago in New York at the global
goalkeepers event
and I was very moved by your
foundation's recognition
of Europe's leadership on global health
and to fight against the covet 19.
the award is truly a collective one
it belongs to all Europeans
who showed such dedication during the
pandemic from the front line workers in
our hospitals and essential services
to the scientists who developed the
life-saving vaccines
and today we are joined by many of you
here from around the world
who are committed to Global health and
equity
so I would like to use this occasion to
reflect on the experience of the
pandemic not from a medical point of
view but from the point of view of it as
a policy maker
and I would like to give a sober
assessment of what I think went well
and where we need to do better in future
I have six lessons that we took
the first lesson not surprisingly is the
utmost importance of solidarity and
cooperation
and let me start with the European
experience
when the covid-19 virus made landfall in
Europe things got really tough at the
beginning
some member states chose to close their
borders for life-saving material and
equipment
there was painful competition for
protective equipment ventilators and
other medical supplies between the
different member states
vaccine nationalism became the norm
around the world
and I can tell you we Europeans had our
tough and painful public discussions
but at a certain point the European
Union decided to take a different path
the path of solidarity and openness
we convinced member states not to close
their borders but to share equipment and
personnel
we decided to buy vaccines together
and not to compete with each other
we started the vaccination campaign on
exec the same day
in all our 27 member states yes we
started with low numbers and that was
heavily criticized but we had a fair
distribution disregard whether you're a
large member state or small one a
wealthy one or not so wealthy one
we decided not to close our borders for
vaccine exports
but to introduce a transparency
mechanism
and at this point many many thanks to
your prime minister the Alexander de
Crowe if it weren't for you you have
been insisting on staying open for
exports because you knew how important
that is for the trust of the
pharmaceutical industry in the location
where they are so today over 80 percent
of the European Union's adult population
is fully vaccinated
while at the same time
we have exported two-thirds of the
vaccines produced in Europe to the rest
of the world
solidarity and openness were the
absolute preconditions to this success
my second lessons
science doesn't exist in a vacuum
I believe it was no coincidence that the
safest and more if most effective
vaccines were developed
and rolled out rapidly in open societies
science depends on cooperation it
depends on education
on the protection of property
intellectual property rights
of course on proper data sharing
but it also depends on individual
Mobility for example freedom to move
and of course on the regulatory
environment and on translating results
into products services and policies
all these factors Empower scientists to
do their best work
and enable Society to reap the benefits
my colleagues and I benefited enormously
from the collective wisdom of scientific
advice
from you Professor Peter piot you were
my personal covet advisor outstanding
the way you gave me on a very on a daily
basis guidance and advice
from my group of covid-19 advisors
hand-picked by you Peter
and also from the platform we created of
27 member States government advisors
so it is transparency and accountability
our freedom of speech
and the freedom of science
that enable good policy making and
innovation
and these are the values that Democratic
societies depend on and nurture
so it was democracies that developed the
life-saving effect of vaccines and that
were best able to support their citizens
when they needed our help the most
my third lesson is about the miracle of
vaccines themselves
as a medical doctor by training
the importance of research and
development development is not news to
me
but the pandemic made it very real for
all of us
as you know the outstanding mRNA
vaccines did not come out of the blue
their Discovery like all Innovation
relies on long-term investment in
scientists and their research
in fact the European commission had been
investing in mRNA vaccine research since
the early 2010s
however
in Europe we did not have a Barda like
in the United States
which prepares for the case of an
emergency
and I must say this was an obvious
disadvantage
so we learned it the rough way
and during the pandemic we created Hera
here are to anticipate threats and
potential Health crisis
now here our works closely with our
Horizon Europe program
the research program
to close the circle from Blue Sky
Discovery all the way to scaling up
life-saving measures
Global cooperation in research and
development is crucial for discovery
that is why for example here in sepi
Coalition for epidemic preparedness
Innovations
for example have recently signed a
letter of intent they will cooperate
on developing Next Generation vaccines
including for covid-19
as part of our vaccines 2.0 strategy
Horizon Europe is providing on a yearly
basis contributions of 35 million
and I'm very pleased
that our clinical trials partnership for
HIV AIDS tuberculosis and malaria
between European
and developing countries
has recently agreed to co-run calls for
proposals with the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation
which takes me to Lesson Four
manufacturing capacity
having safe and effective vaccines is
not enough we all know that we needed
badly the manufacturing capacity as well
as open Supply chains
and I vividly remember that at the
height of the pandemic we saw shortages
of all kinds across the whole vaccine
value chain from bioreactor bags to
vials
from lipids to even syringes
so we set up a task force to work with
industry
with Global Partners
to remove these bottlenecks
this helped ramp up the monthly
production capacity in the European
Union
from 20 million vaccines doses a month
at the beginning of 2021
to around 300 million vaccine doses per
month by the second half of the year
and Having learned this lesson
we have now set up the EU Fab which is
an Ever warm network of production
capacities
to quickly ramp up vaccines production
in the future
ladies and gentlemen
so far Europe has sent more than two and
a half billion coveted vaccine doses to
168 countries worldwide
and this is our fifth lesson
cooperation and solidarity must be
global
at the start of the pandemic there was
no appropriate Global framework to allow
for fair sharing of vaccines and other
medical counter measures
so we helped set up the ACT accelerator
and Kovacs which we financed with 3
billion euros
and we donated half a billion vaccine
doses to lower income countries
but clearly this was not a sufficient
approach more had to be done and more
can be done
and this is why we took a different
approach now
we are supporting developing countries
directly
through financing
through regulatory capacity building
and Technology transfer
to build up their own vaccine
manufacturing capacity
[Applause]
we're working with Senegal Rwanda South
Africa and Ghana to produce mRNA
vaccines that are made in Africa for
Africans
and we are taking a similar approach now
with Latin America they've been asking
us to do the same and of course we
responded positively because this is the
way to go Regional resilience is the the
the solution that builds Global Health
resilience
and the sixth and final lesson concerns
indeed the global Health Systems
over the years
Global Health has been consistently
underfunded and neglected
not by the likes of the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation which is doing
exemplary work but by the governments
and the key is to be prepared and this
means keeping up the investment and
keeping the focus in global Health at
all times even now in these difficult
times was completely different Focus
so I am glad that we agreed finally to
create a pandemic preparedness and
response fund
the European commission together with
the United States have committed 450
million dollars each
and this is just the start
with this reinforced funding
we will step up globally surveillance of
cross-border Health threats
the strengthening of Health Systems
and most importantly the support in
training and education
ladies and gentlemen
I know we still have a long way to go
but thanks to all of you and your
dedication to Global health and equity
I believe we are on the right track
next month the European commission will
bring forward the EU Global Health
strategy it's our proposal to the world
and how to better work together in
Partnership
to advance the common goal of global
health
and of course it will draw on the
lessons I've just outlined to you
I look forward to continuing our work
together closely together with you
and I wish you a rewarding and
thoughtful conference many things for
your attention
foreign
[Music]